we had some actual good news yesterday
it's bad for Republicans it's bad for
people who are looking to suppress the
vote but it's actually good news for
democracy we had pennsylvania supreme
court previously ruled back in january
that the way that the districts are
currently drawn in pennsylvania benefits
republicans in other words it's been
gerrymandered to all hell and back for
the benefit of the republican party and
this is not a shock right there's been a
number of different major efforts in
Pennsylvania for years to combine
gerrymandering with voter ID to help
Republicans win elections and just as a
reminder remember when Mike Terzi the
Speaker of the Pennsylvania House of
Representatives back in the MIT Romney
candidacy days he straight-up talked
about this and and did not even make an
attempt to hide it as anything other
than the political attack that it is
remember this audio voter ID which is
gonna allow Governor Romney to win the
state of Pennsylvania done
[Music]
so anyway that that clip is always just
disturbing as soon as the Pennsylvania
Supreme Court ruled last month that they
need to redraw the districts in
Pennsylvania because it's just again
gerrymandered to hell by Republicans
there was an immediate appeal the
Supreme Court of the United States the
the big Supreme Court not the state
Supreme Court the real one held an
emergency hearing and they decided yeah
the decision from the lower court stands
Pennsylvania is going to have to redraw
those districts and very soon in
accordance with the lower court's order
and when I looked at the numbers the
Pennsylvania gerrymandering is so bad
that even though there are 800,000 more
registered Democrats than Republicans in
Pennsylvania Republicans have held 13 of
the 18 districts during the three
election cycles since the gerrymandering
took place in 2011 not even just a
simple majority I mean has a landslide
different it is a landslide difference
and I know that you know when Trump
gives a speech and the Dow drops 1500
points
this story seems almost too small to
even make a difference but Windsor wins
and this is a win and we should be happy
about it well I guess it's a little bit
of a win but Republicans got to use
their gerrymandered map for reelection
seven out of the ten years that that
would be in place right that's why the
census is so important we have the
census we have redistricting and even if
you immediately identify an injustice in
that districting it can take seven years
to get it fixed and it's important to
clarify the Pennsylvania Court decided
that the gerrymandering violated the
Pennsylvania Constitution and the
Supreme Court agreed there are people
who are misinterpreting or maybe
misreporting this they are confused
there are people who believe because the
Supreme Court agreed with the lower
court ruling what they've said is that
the gerrymandering was unconstitutional
federally that would be so huge because
if the Supreme Court ruled that what
Pennsylvania did violates the Federal
Constitution that becomes precedent in
other states but unfortunately that's
not what the
Preem court ruled the Supreme Court
ruled merely that the Pennsylvania Court
was correct that their state
constitution had been violated period
this says nothing about the
constitutionality of the gerrymandering
ploys that are happening at the federal
constitutional level still the right
decision so I take it that the
Pennsylvania GOP will be back at it in
2021 of course and this is what
Republicans do if you can't win the
hearts and minds of voters over you
start emphasizing voter ID laws and
gerrymander and get any way they can get
an advantage and this is why I've been
saying census census 2020 sounds boring
very very important